[Applause]
to this festive evening on the occasion
of the start of the czech presidency to
the eu
i would like to invite to the stage
prime minister of the czech republic mr
petrov
please welcome president of the european
commission madame ursula fonder lion
[Applause]
of the european union and the national
anthem of the czech republic
do
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
okay
madam president the floor is yours
thank you very much prime minister via
diapeter ladies and gentlemen
thank you for hosting us in this
stunning castle
which is such an amazing musical program
i know and i learned that smetana was
born here in this castle
but i know also that one of the most
famous czech writers of all times
used to live and teach here in lito
michel
the great always rasik
with his novels
he's shown a light on the long history
of the czech people
from the founders of the nation
to the many unsung heroes who marked
with their courage
the history of your country
since here razak's death almost a
century ago
czechia has continued to inspire the
rest of europe
with the stories
of courage
and bravery
i'm talking of course about the heroes
of 1968
and 1989
i am talking of course about watsonville
who was a leader
and a moral inspiration not only for
czechia but for all europeans
but i'm also talking about the czech
heroes of today
czech families have opened their hearts
and their homes
to ukrainian refugees
czech students have volunteered as
babysitters
for ukrainian children in czech cities
tens of thousands of czech people took
to the streets of prague
to protest against the war and to show
solidarity
with ukraine
once again
the czech people are leading by example
in times of hardship
and adversity
for the next six months the czech
republic will lead the european union as
the presidency of the council
a country that unites north and south
east and west
a country that sits at the very center
of europe
geographically
and culturally
a country that has always been at the
center of european history
and i look forward to working very
closely with you dear peter
in the coming six months
because the tasks that await us are
nothing less than historic
we shall support ukraine in their fight
for freedom and help them overcome this
war
we will break free from our dependency
on russian fossil fuels
we will gain independence and security
of energy supply
through more clean and renewable energy
homegrown
creating jobs here in czechia
we will digitize our economy
and make it more resilient
we will strengthen our democracies
and we will protect our people
all of europe
counts on the czech leadership
in the council on all of these vital
issues in the month ahead of us
the tasks may seem daunting
but in challenging times like these
i always remember a sentence by vatslav
havel
which has accompanied me since the very
early days of my own mandate as
president of the european commission
havel used to say
work
work for something because it is good
not just because it stands a chance to
succeed
end of quote
this is what must drive us
the unity of purpose
the strength of our european values
and the passion for freedom that has
inspired
generations of czech heroes
europe's greatest achievements have
always come when we dared to be bold
and i am glad
that in times like these
europe can count on you
the czech republic
and its amazing people
and now
i'm very much looking forward to hear
the amazing music
of smetana thank you very much
[Applause]
okay
you